Evan Carmichael and Oh Nina cutie haha
does it be does it be this be
early just past six I am super tired I
lost my voice from salsa dancing and he
came last night anywhere off to go to
the League of Legends tournament first
step I need some coffee how you doing
yeah there's something that feels wrong
about waking up at six a.m. on a
saturday morning when it's still dark to
go watch a video game but there's
something so right about it too hey I
thought I asked this morning I woke up
on my throat sore Nina was crashing it
and I said do you want to cancel today
Nina said hey we're paying I paid how
much you paid sixty bucks to go watch a
video game and wake up and insane
anymore luck either an insane early time
after halloween party but you gotta do
stuff that's crazy right otherwise life
is boring let's go get some coffee
you
all right we're here he's gonna pull up
the tickets love the tickets read it out
loud Evan Carmichael and Oh Nina cutie
haha
nina cutie pike hey bud doesn't it take
it all right here we go this is the
lineup to get in some people came in
costume where's your costume Nina you
know you're going as a Chinese girl oh
you have a great costume ok so it's
quick context every year league of
legends has an annual tournament where
the best teams around the world compete
against each other the Koreans are
always the best I always cheer for north
america I want us to make a strong
representation but we never quite make
it this year I think we did a little
better than most top two teams of korean
won as SKT has the legendary faker on
their team and you know he's considered
the Michael Jordan of eSports and
basically all the best players they
haven't lost a single game this entire
tournament they're going up against the
koo tigers and we are all here to watch
them play a best-of-five series to see
who can take home the world championship
SKT is one it before note no team has
ever won it twice so we'll see if they
can repeat I'm chewing for them we'll
see what happens
okay we got some lungs drive we don't
get items miss you try the strategy as
well early on the guards oh wow these
are porous these are little characters
and that's it's really understand the
greatness that is morrowind respond to
candy hearts because that was all he was
the Commission to say here
you
one marred into the fight now grow and
prey on the target
it's going to be curl going down SKT
seemingly pulling this one back in their
favor
Raj coronal
while growth is down the first one is
gorilla they have Bray in the perfect
spot and they take down prey they take
down gorilla and it's just chaos or two
they cannot find the right positioning
sk down the lane bojan can't even help
on the outside right now somehow who
gets out only losing brain oh there goes
Hogan SKT is two wins away from the
summoner's Cup set1 game one Nina kind
of fell asleep
pionship finals
hold on tight
quickly
goes in a fight with a nice question
down here comes Kuro grows down the
chaos storm it's all over wolf though
bakery just completely turned this game
that's the end from wall stops up three
members slicing Maelstrom goes down but
it's not really hitting anybody or
setting the targets it needs bouts a
double kill for bangee they're not
stopping bank jumps over the wall for
another kill and it looks like it's
going to be an ace in the base sk
telecom t1 are one win away from being
your two-time world champion
Oh
I mean our as herself the Chinese
princesses beautify Chinese princess
it's working out perfectly distributing
the kills nice bang trying to come in
now
the special design he does not get crowd
control that's a grand challenge
together
go little teen gets hit by the turret
off banker over the wall a shutdown
that's huge cold for faker coming in
from hojin this is gonna be mine going
down as well as he's too far from home
whoa bangs gonna go down out we're going
to a game 4
the t-shirt DeMuth too cold when you can
make
as I work my champion selection alright
guys so obviously you got to find a spot
you know just get everybody just get
down you don't have to you know stress
yourself lay down through the bridge try
not to fall asleep beside you're even up
for about 36 hours or whatever I Stacy
squad let's get comfortable get on the
floor
now about this push-up Ava's I've ever
even seen they're well on track to
become the most dominant world's
performing team and the scary thing
about it is how easy they have made it
look they have a chance to be the first
real League of Legends dynasty and they
take the brain they take down gorilla
and it's just chaos
his two wins away from the summoner's
Cup hey jump
for another kill and it looks like it's
gonna be
sk telecom t
from being your
ambience
for the first time as katie is booted we
are the lies doing
SKT is it bringing their a-game and they
even opened up Pandora's box
will be your first ever
world champions
all right game is over yeah fun yes did
you fall asleep no didn't fall asleep so
little contacts little extra context
again I said at the top that SKT was the
favorite and and they again they went
undefeated did the titans in the
industry they spent the most money had
the biggest staff the New York Yankees
Manchester United New England Patriots
all rolled into one the heavy favorites
and the koo tigers that they went up
against we're just kind of thrown
together don't have as big a coaching
staff massive underdogs nobody really
knew about them they had to such a
moment where they said all we want is
for people to cheer our names because
everybody back home always cheers SKT
SKT like we just want once for people to
cheer our names and they ended up losing
three games to one but in that one game
everybody was cheering them on and I'm
sure it was a big highlight for all of
them and we were cheering them on and it
was fun come use against all wanna hurt
80 talented team won its approval to a
German clear now wouldn't know haha Inc
Eagle ningun who you know boy or
illogical Suzie Ketcham on oh yeah hey
Johnny IE mhm guys today Bannon hago
Penderecki d McCartan young girl pooja
to boot a certain go cougar chongqing
you invoke will enter a mantra washburn
for Tyler Wonka fanatic frantic Toronto
de la camara smoochy kiss what's to talk
about
trying to stop SKT let's still some
respect for my colleagues are you Tigers
and from SKT as well great sportsmen
they're showing love for our runners-up
I mean what an incredible run they had
as well that can't be true love it you
gotta love to look at their faces about
the attitude the attitude that brought
them to the finals will carry them out
of the finals they may have lost but
they still had such an incredible but
they won our hearts a 10 by far and away
so that's it we're really tired even
though it's only noon we're gonna get
some lunch maybe sleep party no that's
it party last night okay okay well have
an amazing weekend thank you for joining
us for ours continue to believe and
we'll see you soon
okay i know we said goodbye and faked
you all out but two things one you can't
have a league tournament game final
without then enjoying some nice poutine
after we're here at smokes Poochyena
rhian adelaide street west here in
Toronto to scowl down second thing if
you want to play with me if your league
player you want to join my mind handle
on the North American server is believed
team look me up add me as a friend happy
to get a game in I hover between silver
three and silver for so just set your
expectations alright this is awesome
routine this is Evan as a routine I got
their tables up to the one whole pork
Philly cheesesteak Nina said she wanted
something different this is it
now it's good bacteria we're going to
enjoy this have a good weekend guys
position